as you mentioned a moment ago 59 people
were wounded and are in the hospital
today
Jonathan Vigliotti is at the Royal
Manchester infirmary Jonathan and Scott
this is one of eight hospitals that took
in those 59 victims were told that 12
people are currently being treated here
inside all of them under the age of 16
she came home for Nicole she Lucas to
the audience and then some of the
victims brought to this hospital were
reportedly paralyzed by shrapnel for the
capacity crowd inside Manchester Arena
it was disorderly everybody's pushing
everybody shoving the shoes being lost
phones being drop girls are crying and
we saw these women being treated by
paramedics they had like walking wounds
on the legs
no shoes it was just chaos Karen Ford
was inside with her 13 year old daughter
when the bomb went off she said her
husband panicked when he couldn't find
them in the aftermath what about 10
minutes we were trying to look for each
other they thought we were dead the
great city of manchester has been
affected by terrorism before the UK's
home secretary noted how this strike
seemed to target innocence this time it
has been a particular attack on the most
vulnerable in our society very very low
Katie don't worry very lucky we got out
of there early when the husband said
there's been a terrorist attack ariana
grande I didn't quite believe him after
the terror there was comfort on the
streets of Manchester
now there's resolve Manchester mayor
Andy Burnham these were children young
people and their families that those
responsible chose to terrorize and kill
this was an evil act and when the
concert came to an end last night
hundreds of balloons were dropped from
the ceiling some concert goers thought
the explosion was part of the
celebration at this point it's still
unclear Scott how many
they're missing Jonathan Vigliotti fours
this morning Jonathan thank you well
it's about 3:15 in the afternoon here in
Manchester this is normally a very busy
part of the city but Manchester to a
great degree is a quiet and somber place
today there's a electronic billboard
just half a block away from here that
says simply pray for Manchester back to
you with the broadcast centre a lot of
people are doing that today thank you
very much Scott